still quinces with us do you remember
opening your exam results i do 22 or so
years ago i remember the nervousness
sort of heading into school to get them
yeah when i did it it used to be
actually pinned up on the wall so
everybody could see what your results
were
yeah i know
thankfully i did well in english not so
good in maths uh what is the overall
picture looking like so we'll have to
wait and see um so the results will be
out very very soon but i think the first
thing is date is today is a celebration
of all those young people's achievements
and efforts over the course of the past
two years so today is about saying huge
well done and a huge thank you to all of
the teachers and the school leaders and
of course parents and carers that are
supported young people to get those
results and you know i wish them every
success with what they go on to do next
the grades are going to be lower though
aren't they so yet they are and and
that's very much part of part of the
plan so over the last couple of years
we've had teacher assess grades we've
gone back for the first time to
examinations but we've done that in a
staged way so it's not just back to pure
examinations we recognize the fact that
young people have faced huge disruption
of the past couple of years so there
have been adaptations in place and
ofqual have reflected it in their
marking and grading
but looking up um what we put into
catch-up funding as opposed to what
other countries do uh the netherlands um
catch up funding per pupil was 2100
pounds ours was 310 pounds how can that
be satisfactory so i think it's
difficult to make international
comparisons in that way because we have
very different systems we put in place
around 5 billion pounds of support
and that's targeted to those who needed
it the most um
we we keep a real watchful eye on these
things and we continue to look at exam
results and things like our education
improvement areas around the country
looking at how we can
reduce the
attainment
attainment gap and make sure wherever
you live in this country you're getting
a world-class education and the same
opportunity to thrive okay let's keep it
within our borders then if you don't
want to compare it to other countries
close to us
the then
tsar sir kevin collins who had been
asked to come up with his view on how
much government spending should be to
try to improve our education system he
said 15 billion pounds worth of funding
that was totally rejected and he
resigned as a result he did we put in
place uh around five billion pounds of
funding i'm not gonna say i said but
that's 10 billion less
compared to what he what he asked for at
that time and that's of course the start
we keep this under review and the
previous education secretary and the
current education secretary has said the
same we keep a watchful eye on these
things we continue to invest in
education and if we need to invest more
of course we will but i think what
today's about is about celebrating those
gcse results and these young people up
and down the country that worked
incredibly hard we've made adaptations
deliberately to reflect the fact that
young people have faced that disruption
but if you look at the national tutoring
program so some 1.8 billion pound
program which continues now uh that
delivered around 2 million courses up
and down the country those who we know
have got the shortest amount of time
left in education so the 16 to 19 year
olds they're getting those extra 40
hours at a cost of some 800 million so
the investment is going in we keep our
watch for life we need to invest more i
have no reservations about going to the
treasury and asking for that so it's
wrong to say that we invest less in
students now than we did in 2010.
so i think that
there are competing arguments on this in
terms of
whether you you sort of budgeted
inflation for that but of course you
know we continue to invest i think
around an additional 7 billion pounds
over this sr period so an extra 4
billion pounds into our school budget
this year i think the overall education
budget is around 86
billion pounds so we do invest huge
amounts into into education but as i say
today is about celebrating the success
of all of those gcse students up and
down the country and who are looking
forward to going on taking their next
steps in education what are you putting
regional disparities down to
so i think there have always been uh
regional disparities for all sorts of
reasons it's why we've got the education
of the 55
educational investment areas up and down
the country in part it's because there
are some areas of the country where we
find it challenging to attract and
recruit teachers especially high caliber
and high quality teachers so for example
we have the grants in place in some of
those educational attainment areas in
some cases it's around early years the
importance of the the sort of one to one
to five but it but we continue to focus
on it because it's huge it's hugely
important that wherever you live is part
of our leveling up agenda wherever you
live in this country you should have
access to a world-class education a
fantastic school in college and go on to
achieve whatever you uh you know your
your uh uh your your potential okay now
i'm sure some of our viewers watching
this morning will like me have gone
through the three-day week and the power
blackouts in the 1970s the latest i'm
hearing is that some schools might only
be able to run three days a week because
they cannot afford the energy bills what
are you doing to help them
so a number of things so the first thing
is additional funding so an extra seven
billion pounds over this spending review
period an extra four billion pounds uh
this year so significant just for energy
bills no of course it's not so so it's
about giving them energy bills and and
also um
increase increase to uh staffing and
staff wages so we keep a watchful eye i
mean some schools will be uh under under
long-term contracts others will be
coming out of those contracts i'm
keeping a watchful eye i listen to
schools and school leaders up and down
the country and as i say we'll be
working with the new prime minister and
the new secretary of state and the new
government which we'll have in just a
couple of weeks time uh to look at some
of the challenges we face and what we
may need to do to acknowledge that some
schools might not be able to open five
days a week so no i don't accept that
and we we expect schools to be open five
days a week and over 70 percent of
schools already do a 32.5 hour week um
the ifs indeed have looked at schools
and and they they have said that um
schools schools should be able to manage
within their existing budgets but look
i'm alive to the fact that energy costs
are increasing uh at a significant rate
we see that in our household bills it
will be the same in uh commercial and
indeed schools so keep a very watchful
eye and continue to work
yeah i saw bruce johnson yesterday had
gone to ukraine to offer
his support the six-month
anniversary that's the right word of the
invasion
by russia and he says that we need to
continue on the path that we're on
because they're paying in blood we're
paying in higher bills what if people
can't afford to pay their higher bills
well i i know how concerned people are
especially ahead of the price cap
announcement
tomorrow uh what i would say to them is
there is already a 37 billion pound
package of support that's been put in
place not enough
well most of which hasn't actually come
into effect yet so the 400 pounds for
every household we've had the first 300
pound cost of living payment there will
be a second one towards the end of this
year 150 pounds for pensioners 150
pounds for those who on
disability benefits and that's exactly
why the government has always said and
indeed both of the leadership contenders
have said that their first act will be a
uh fiscal event where they will look at
what more support we can provide to
people but as i said that 37 billion
pound package support is in place 400
pounds for every household coming in the
autumn but i know how worried people are
about it and more support will come and
i say i'm pleased to see that both
leadership contenders and we'll have a
new prime minister in just a couple of
weeks time their number one priority
alongside their chancellor will be to
support people through this now i know
that you um you're not really got
involved in the leadership debate and
sorry you support rishi sooner but i've
not heard you speak too much about it
but i do want to put this to you because
you are a conservative senior minister
um a senior ally of liz trust has said
this morning that sunak is thrashing
around all over the place like a wounded
stoat his attacks um a weasel if you
don't know what one is his attacks are
framing us as taury scum
this is not what you need is it well i i
haven't i haven't seen seen this in the
times happening well i haven't seen i
haven't seen those comments as it was
early start this morning so i haven't
read okay i've read the times check my
word for what i will do but what i would
say on that is what one of the things
that i found most difficult about the
leadership contest has been the sort of
blue on blue which i think is totally
unnecessary both candidates should just
present their positive vision for our
country and the most important thing is
that in two weeks time so on on tuesday
the sixth when we have a new prime
minister that we all as a parliamentary
party get behind that new leader get
behind that prime minister and we
continue to deliver for the british
people that's what i want to see do you
think boris johnson has done enough in
this period between him stepping down
and the new minister the new prime
minister taking over it's been described
as a zombie government on more than one
occasion yeah i i don't recognize that
that picture and certainly from an
education perspective we've been working
hard on exam results the work that we'd
started around the send review around
the uh the green paper the work we're
doing around reforming children social
care that has all continued and it will
continue to continue and hard-working
civil servants alongside ministers up
and down
whitehall are working to ensure that the
new government will be it's not just
going to be starting from fresh they
will have a suite of options that
they'll be able to take forward
alongside ongoing 2019 manifesto
commitments that we are yet to deliver
and working hard on so i don't recognize
the picture that's painted and as far as
i'm concerned the prime minister has
always shown a massive interest in
education and what i've been doing both
in the children families brief and also
in the schools brief and i've no doubt
he'd continue to do so even though he's
working from home his country home
mostly
let's end where we started and uh a word
for those that don't get the gcse
results they're hoping for so don't
panic it really isn't the end of the
world there have never been more options
for post 16 than there are now so
whether you go on to do a levels t
levels which is our exciting new uh
technical vocational qualifier
qualification um whether you go on to
further education whether you go on uh
to an apprenticeship which is probably
more and more popular
there are so many options to you don't
panic speak to your college uh speak
speak to your parents uh you will be
able to achieve your potential just
don't panic how did you do
i it was a long time ago i got six a's
and four b's as i did as i recorded um
a levels didn't go quite quite so well
right but i really enjoyed my time at
school and that's the most important
thing you know your grades are important
but they don't define you uh just have a
plan b i hope you all young people down
in the country get the grades they want
to need today if you don't don't panic
there are so many options open to you
good to see you mister thanks very much